it's time for drew's news the only news
with the portable desk including a mess
and with me at the traveling desk is my
trusty co-pilot and just one of the
loves of my
and life season our motto is
we'll travel
as you can see ross and i are taking our
little news show on the road all across
america and i'm thrilled to kick it off
right here in my hometown right in front
of the hollywood sign i mean how crazy
is it see i love this drew you know i
thought we had fun in season one now we
are on the road so watch out america
we're coming we'll be doing this all
season long so if you want the desk in
your hometown
we would like you to reach out to us and
let us know send us a message on social
media and tell us where the desk should
go next
maybe we'll be in your town watch out um
okay so for the last month everyone's
been asking one big question splish
splash should we be taking less baths
vogue reports that it's the latest trend
in hollywood hygiene ashton kutcher and
mila kunis say that they only bathe
themselves and their kids when they see
dirt dax shepherd and kristen bell say
their family waits until they smell the
stink
and jake gyllenhaal says he barely
showers because quote we naturally clean
ourselves and you know the ladies are
like okay
um ross to bathe or not to bathe that is
the question what do you think
do what you want if you want to save it
until you smell the stink before you
bathe good for you but not not ross
matthews i don't play like that i don't
know like i just feel like i can't be my
best self unless i smell artificially
clean
what do you guys think raise your hand
if you think that you don't really need
showers all the time
thank you
thank you and by the way i mean we have
to acknowledge the fact that someone i
am the biggest fan of uh seth um mr dude
with sign
i want to know do you have any
breadcrumbs of a trail that traces back
to kind of how this really started dude
with sign that now has eight million
followers basically yes so basically i
was working for a card game company and
i was writing just like funny jokes and
we were also trying to do funny content
every day just for fun and one day we
tried one that said stop replying all to
company-wide emails
we were we were emailing and it was
someone's birthday and then everyone was
replying all saying like oh my god happy
birthday jenna like it was just really
annoying and we were like oh we should
go protest this seth you'll do it and i
was like i'll do it
went out there and did it and it blew up
everyone really liked it and i was just
kind of like we could probably keep
doing this yeah it definitely worked out
and then you're hanging out with justin
bieber drew barrymore what's up
[Laughter]
you also were just at the white house in
the oval office with biden yes all right
next up one of hollywood's finest
christopher maloney you know him well
recently he was on the cover of men's
health looking like a total zaddy at age
60. he's 60 years old you guys but now
the new york post reports dictionary.com
just added the word zaddy and it's
defined as an attractive man who's also
charming and self-confident and if you
look it up
my picture's right there no
chris maloney says now that he knows
what it means he is happy to be
america's zaddy look at this daddy chris
maloney oh my gosh
all right well next up apparently it's
not just jen and ben who are getting
back together a new relationship study
says many people hook up with their exes
and you know what women i didn't mean to
point at you women
we've oh i've gone around the bed with
the exercises
that's what we do
it's because you're convinced that it's
unrequited maybe you've changed maybe
it's unfinished anyway keep going well
women i would say women do it more than
men do and it sounds like you are one of
them yeah women and homes says the study
found that 54 percent of women had slept
with an ex while only 14 of them
actually wanted to get back together
they were like
i quit it but i could still hit it
dude with a sign what do you think
[Laughter]
and yet you can never tell them because
guess what the second they get back
together you're in the doghouse
now this story is my favorite of the day
we've got some really great news for
students and families right here in
california cnn is reporting that the
state is offering universal free lunch
to all
public school students this fall wow
nearly 60 percent of the students
qualify for free lunch or reduced lunch
but this year thanks to the work of over
200 organizations every student will get
a balanced nutritious lunch free of
charge and free of stigma
california is the very first state to
get this done
not only am i so in awe of this i want
to know how we can take this across our
country yes california thank you for
setting the bar may we all follow in
your footsteps an example
[Music]